hi I'm Dan Ratcliffe I'm Evan Rachel
Wood and we are here with BuzzFeed to
take the co-star quiz oh God
you found the perfect point to break and
carry on this is going to go well we're
already inside
[Music]
so I I do not know I do not argue about
that I don't know your birthday but I
might know your sign so what's your
birthday it's September September 7th no
I couldn't have guessed that okay are
you a cancer
I am on the custom layout so yeah
your hometown I think I I can have a
guess okay are you
maybe you're just there a lot now oh I
see yeah perhaps yeah are you just
London like true and true okay yeah
nothing interesting about it uh you are
yeah
but that's wrong you just go but is it
like is it one of the Carolinas yes is
it Raleigh yes oh hey okay wow really
good your first acting gig was Miracle
Worker production no close oh that was
one of my first I don't know your first
acting gag I it wasn't it like yeah TV
movie yeah in England or something okay
yeah it was pretty close yeah I don't
know the name it's David Copperfield
that's it yeah based on a famous
magician
the first time we met was we both know
that that's just dinner we're just using
memory yes yes yeah yeah I passed you on
the street once and he doesn't remember
it up I blanked you one time
their favorite swear word I don't know
yours I feel like you and you are good
at swearing and enjoy it I don't know
what you're you do know me so well
Maybe
I don't know okay no I mean it's the f
word all the way for everybody right
yeah pretty much yeah like I'm English
so I like other words that uh viewed is
really horrible bollocks yes bollocks is
a good one that is fun yeah go to
karaoke zone is What's Up by 4 Non
Blondes that's it
I have been witness to it and it is
pretty inspectacular is yours um The
Real Slim Shady
one of them it's a toss-up between that
or then Aaron and I duetting on uh
Celine Dion Oh Celine Dion right yeah
that was amazing I've also for
witnessing that and that is incredible
yeah just the full version not a radio
edit down yeah there was choreography
that was just instinctual their
childhood celebrity crush we were just
talking about this actually
um there was I know that you liked Kate
Hudson and Drew Barrymore yes but the
main one was Cameron Diaz Cameron Diaz
that's right yeah we also talked about
almost in The Mask in The Mask yes okay
so I do know that
um you were a lot of ice skaters but
also Jonathan Taylor Thomas that's
correct
yeah were you doing a play
no
and I can't remember either so you're
fine I don't know mere corkers yeah
maybe it was Miracle work yeah yeah that
makes sense
no it wasn't that
what is it oh was it the central black
movie no oh damn I think I might have
just been off products they're working
on next uh you're doing a play I'm doing
a play and uh you are chilling out and
waiting to hear about Westworld that's
true it's great there's so many of these
answers I know
their dressing room must have an
accordion yeah
um and their dressing room must have a
person next door to them playing
accordion correct yeah
favorite way down song is this is Yoda
uh-huh and yours changes but right now
it's Jurassic Park
this is a fun test actually you should
do a thing here's a new idea for
BuzzFeed at the end of a drum kit you
should just do a thing where everyone
has to give the other person's answers
to the junk kit question we could do
this and we could do it their go-to
activity between films we probably can't
say nobody can't say
again that makes it sound like we're
doing we're shooting guns
um well sometimes we played heads up
that's true yeah yeah heads up became
big towards the end of the shoot that
was really fun favorite scene shot
together I mean I love the dino scene
because it's just so completely sincere
and then goes insane yes
um I love the diner scene and the one
with Josh made me laugh so much when
you're when you get the phone call oh
yes eat it and you're smashing the phone
that was amazing your favorite snack at
craft Services Coffee iced coffee
[Music]
what is yours I don't know gum gum
[Music]
and the last TV show they binge watched
wasn't it something really it was
something really cheesy that you were
like I'm kind of embarrassed to say that
I binged this it wasn't like the
Bachelor or something like that it was
like oh no it was the the one where
people get married right when they meet
right love is blind yeah yeah love is
blind I probably had just finished
watching that when I when we watched
together
um yeah uh and I don't what I don't I
bet I bet you're do you watch reality I
I watch Like house renovation shows okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna guess then
um Love It or List It
oh no anything like on the Magnolia
Network big Joanna Gaines like nerd over
here so yeah and we're done we did
pretty well this has 11 out of 15 to me
yeah 11 out of 15. yeah it says we're
basically the same person right well
after doing interviews next to each
other yeah that will help you yeah I
can't believe I missed the camera Diaz
question I knew that thank you BuzzFeed
thanks BuzzFeed and everybody be sure to
watch uh weird the Al Yankovic story on
Roku when it comes out on November 4th
for free for free
foreign
[Music]